-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since lots of shows are
gearing up for their finales,
I sent out
a #AddAWordRuinATVShow.
I asked you guys
to take the title of a TV show,
add one word,
change the meaning.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic.
So thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love that. We love
when you play along. Thank you.
So I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#AddAWordRuinATVShow tweets
from you guys.
This first one is
from @marisarosie22.
She says,
"Dora the Ford Explorer."
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ghost7.
-Ooh!
-Yeah.
They say,
"The Kinda Good Doctor."
[ Laughter ]
-He's alright.
-He's okay.
This one's from @shyshellz.
-Aw.
-They say, "Baby Shark Tank."
[ Laughter ]
This one's
from @oakridgeaussies.
They say,
"Vanilla Ice Road Truckers."
[ Laughter ]
What's he up to, man?
-He's doing a fix-it show,
isn't he?
-What is he on?
-Home improvement show.
-He does, right?
-Yeah.
-I saw him in something.
He was funny.
-The Ice Man?
-Yeah.
You call him the Ice Man?
-Dude.
[ Laughter ]
-You used to hang around
with him and Snow, right?
-Uh, Sir Hable Snow?
[ Laughter ]
-"Informer," yeah.
-Yeah, man.
That was "Informer," dude.
I use to hang out with Snow
all the time, dude,
just talk about stuff.
I'm like, "Write that down."
[ Laughter ]
The Ice Man, dude, I used to
hang out with him all the time.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-What would you guys talk about?
-"Top Gun."
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
So you and Vanilla Ice
would get together.
-Uh-huh. That's right.
-Right?
And you'd just talk about
the movie "Top Gun."
-That's correct.
-And pretty much
that's all you would do?
-"You there, Goose?
I'm not hearing you, Goose."
[ Laughter ]
Stuff like that.
-Stuff like that.
-Yeah.
-"Need for speed,"
things like that. Great.
-Yeah.
"You there, Goose?
I can't hear you, buddy."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ryanschwartz.
He says, "Zoey's Extraordinary
Polka Playlist."
Hey, that's good.
-Oh, yeah.
-I'd watch that.
This one's from @smith1226peter.
He says,
"My Stripper Name Is Earl."
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty good.
This one's
from @joseramonmarmtz.
He says,
"Meet the Panini Press."
Oh, Chuck Todd
hosts that as well.
-Nice.
-This one's from @kissmetkarma.
She says, "It's Showtime
at the Apollo 13."
-Sandman, we have a problem.
-This is --
[ Laughter ]
Sandman?
This one's from @ginboswick.
She says, "America's Next
Top Model Airplane."
-Oh, I like that.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's
from @ryanbartholomee.
He says, "How to Get Away
with Murder Hornets."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @sohnzie.
-Sohnzie?
-Yeah, she says,
"Who's the Cake Boss?"
[ Laughter ]
"Mona!"
-"Angela!"
-"Angela!
Samantha!"
[ Laughter ]
"Jonathan!"
This one's from @marksaun.
He says, "Young Rock Collector."
Oh, that's --
Got that on the DVR.
This one's from @teawithtammy1.
She says,
"How I Met Your Real Mother."
Oh, hey.
-Oh. Ouch.
-Here's another one
from @kissmetkarma.
She says,
"All My Children's Fault."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Last one here is
from @shejstaz.
She says,
"Curb Your Dogecoin Enthusiasm."
There you have it. Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.